I want to talk about Willard mittens
Romney the former aha actually noted
middle name's not really mittens
although something like two or four
percent of voters into thin 2012 thought
that it was and I guess I became one of
those uh Willard Mitt Romney is his
actual name he now is buddy-buddy with
president-elect Donald he has put out a
statement with a major show of support
for Trump as our president he is
potentially still being considered to be
Secretary of State who knows at this
point Kellyanne Conway said over the
weekend that many Trump supporters would
feel betrayed if Romney was picked as
Secretary of State so why is this
interesting it's interesting because
Romney was one of trumps harshest
critics during the campaign and i'm not
talking about political policy critiques
I'm talking about personal attacks
remember some of these comments up for
example Trump is a con man said Mitt
Romney about Donald during the perdia
presidential election Trump is a phony
Trump is a fraud Trump promised Trump's
promises are as worthless as a degree
from Trump University Trump is playing
the American public for suckers and
Trump has neither the temperament nor
the judgment to be President those
aren't exactly the critiques where he
can say all you know what I've heard now
what his policy will be and I don't
think that these are pretty serious
personal attacks I would love to see too
if Donald Trump is just goading Mitt
Romney into to go back on all his past
comments yeah embarrass himself publicly
only to give him a glimmer of hope and
then strip it away from a min Pacific
someone else and not make him Secretary
of State now Trump also called Romney a
choke artist and irrelevant so what
happened here I know you read these
details Rachel they're amazing but Trump
and Romney and rents Priebus who I mean
is one of the most horrible people
there's going to be involved in this in
this abortion of an administration they
had a nice dinner in a French restaurant
at a trump hotel in Manhattan and after
it outcomes Romney totally different
person than the guy we saw at that
speech in Utah during the presidential
campaign and says quote I had a
wonderful evening with president elect
Trump and it turns out that they dined
on garlic soup with frogs legs scallops
steak and lamb chops those frogs legs
that is the way to court people i
imagine that romney was sitting there
skeptical with his bowl of soup any sort
of spooning through it and then up comes
a frog leg he says wait wait wait frogs
legs I now believe Donald Trump can lead
us forward in this country I don't know
if that's what happened but the
explanation has to be equally absurd
given the level of critique that we
heard from mittens isn't it I'm I'm sure
it's the frogs legs no I I think that
his is flip flopping in the passive gay
marriage and abortion in it now is flip
flopping on Trump is just showing kind
of his quest for power cuz I really
don't believe unfortunately that it's he
feels this duty or call to service I
think it's the latter well that was one
of the critiques of Romney during the
2012 campaign remember Pat when people
said you know it's not even so much that
I disagree with Romney on on all policy
moderates would say it's just the idea
that he doesn't really think anything
it's just what position can I take to
craft my public persona and platform and
that's exactly what Trump did yeah even
when he made those critical statements
of Trump there were people who thought
that the Republican convention would be
brokered and someone would have to come
in from the outside and he would be the
one points to do that and maybe we'll go
opportunist certainly two sides on this
rekindling between Romney and the
involvement of people like him with the
Trump administration one side is this is
good right a more reasonable Republican
voice is a good thing and Romney is way
more reasonable than people like penson
Steve Bannon and jeff Sessions now when
you hear me say that it's crazy that
that I'm saying the guy who strapped the
dog to the roof of his car is the voice
of reason in a sea of insanity but that
happens to be the case right now the
other side rachel is if Trump goes to
establishment with his cabinet it may
end up being indistinguishable from a
sort of normal crony capitalist
establishment Republican administration
and it might be perceived as sort of
doing a good job which is really scary
to think but it's already not going in
that direction well it's 5050 if right
if some like romney is involved it helps
us go back towards establishment Steve
Bannon being involved goes towards crazy
all right xenophobic white supremacist
the direction uh but but I that's my
concern if it goes to establishment
maybe some people will say this isn't
really that different than George
w bush yeah who would be behind making
it more establishment oh because it
wouldn't be Trump it would be pence it
would be previous it would be sort of
those establishment voices I would think
uh we'll we'll keep following it but
frogs legs clearly changing Mitt
Romney's mind